ici devant la gare centrale de kram à
tort qu'il ya très exactement un mois
cinquante neuf personnes ont été tuées
par une frappe de missile il s'agissait
de civils qui tentaient de fuir l'est de
l'ukraine cette frappe est l'une des
pires qui aurait ciblé des civils depuis
le début de la guerre aujourd'hui crama
torse c'est presque vidée de ses
habitants et certains préfèrent rester
malgré les appels répétés des autorités
locales pour qu'ils quittent la ville et
ageas et radio je suis né ici c'est ma
ville g à tort ce que survivra il y a
beaucoup d' usine ici c'est pourquoi ils
vont la défendre et ils continueront à
la défense
les imbéciles n'ont pas peur tout le
monde a peur de ça mais depuis le début
j'ai décidé avec ma famille que nous
n'irions nulle part ce qui doit arriver
arrivera j'aime ma ville et je ne veux
pas partir qui a besoin de réfugiés
personnes
les autorités locales disent qu'elles
sont prêtes à s'occuper des 50000
personnes qui restent akram atallah mais
les craintes aujourd'hui se concentre
sur la russie et sur ses plans à venir
week-end
ils peuvent mener plus d'attaqués par
des missiles des roquettes des bombes
nous pensons que notre ville est en
première ligne quelle est la cible des
russes car peut-être qu'il envisagerait
d'en faire le centre administratif de la
partie nord de la région de donetsk
le 9 mai pourrait changer la donne dans
la guerre en cours en ukraine si
vladimir poutine décide d'élargir ou pas
la portée de son invasion mais si le
courage et la détermination que nous
avons vu chez les habitants qui refusent
de quitter crama torse et le donbass en
général est la même que celle de la
mairie kahnienne des troupes russes vont
devoir faire face à certains de leurs
combats les plus durs à ce jour